hello everyone good afternoon my name is
Jessica Tyler I'm a data scientist over
at hellofresh and the marketing realm of
things and the topic I'm going to be
talking with you all today is going to
be you know how we at hellofresh used
Geo experiments combined with causal
impact in order to measure increment
allottee and before I hop completely
over into that just wanted to give you a
little bit of information about myself
why not so as I said before working at
hellofresh been there about two years
now and because we are a multi brand
company have become one I also have the
privilege to work on questions related
to these two other lovely meal kit
brands green chef as well as every plate
previously I was working in advanced
analytics also on the marketing side at
Haynes Brands Inc so if you guys have
any Haynes underwear champion socks in
your door in a waiter welcome oh and
then before that I did a little bit of a
stint at catalyst which is a political
consulting firm that maintains a large
voter file also does a lot of propensity
modeling around people who vote in the
United States LinkedIn that link is
there add me and really moving on into
what incrementality is so as a marketing
person really I'm going to be talking
about the topic in that context and the
way we tend to look at it is the measure
of lift that advertising spending
provides to our conversion rate so
typically you know we kind of have this
sort of situation here say that your
marketing activity before campaign is
pretty stable you're spending about the
same amount of money you have a little
bit of a stable conversion rate maybe if
you come to see on the graph the slope
is slipping upward you know you're
growing a bit which is good and then you
kind of have
a campaign that you launched and you
really do Ramba that spend and you also
see that your conversion rates are
increasing as well what do you want to
figure out is what the difference
between what you would have seen had you
kept that spend constant is versus what
you actually observe so that's kind of
your lift and we really want to measure
that why so within marketing we tend to
think of a variety of channels that we
have to access our customers at the
different stages of really awareness all
the way to conversion that people could
be going through and we kind of know
that certain channels are better for
certain stages than others so for
instance when we kind of look at that
upper funnel one maybe like someone
hasn't necessarily heard of hellofresh
maybe they know of the concept of meal
kits but they don't really recognize
your brand places like TV billboards
those sorts of upper funnel channels
you're going to be putting spend there
and probably they're going to eventually
lead to a conversion but it's gonna take
some time and if you go off of
traditional ways of measuring what
causes conversions like let's say you
are looking in Google Analytics and
typically you use last-click to decide
who gets the credit for that conversion
it's probably come going to come to
somewhere like paid search
you know once someone is more aware it's
likely that they're not going to
directly type into their browser
hellofresh comm and they're going to go
into google and they're maybe going to
click on a paid search ad that says hey
$20 offer actually $40 off your first
two boxes then $20 and $10 I know that's
our discount that we're offering and
they're gonna could eventually convert
off of that and who doesn't get the
credit from that your TV your billboards
so how do we kind of measure the impact
of that fairly and you know when it
comes
- whether we do see an increase in
conversions because of those activities
that we have we want to really know like
and be confident is that a result of
that campaign how do you know that it's
that in particular and not something
else that's going on and even if you do
see a significant increase in your
conversions how much are you even paying
for it can you justify to your
stakeholders that they should be doing
more of that in the future and so
imagine your so let's say you were just
chilling catching up with SML a YouTube
ad like that pops up on your feed maybe
you're interested but chances are you
aren't going to interrupt you know Pete
Davidson and go ahead and convert right
away so it's gonna be hard to measure
what impact that sort of ad is going to
have on who eventually converts and you
know I took all these screenshots in
case the video didn't work
scary asa so really when we had a
situation like this we had ads like this
running
we had some YouTube activity but we
wanted to see whether a ramping up spend
in this channel would really be
worthwhile to us like is it scalable
will it bring enough conversions to
justify that extra spend what we wanted
to decide that based on is incremental
cost per action so in this case cost per
conversion and luckily we kind of
already knew how the channel had been
doing before and simply what we wanted
to decide is
whether the incremental CPA that we were
about to measure was above or you know
at the same place or below that
benchmark and if it was then you know
great let's do more of it if not
probably you know leave it alone for an
hour or try something different later in
terms of you know how we were going to
set up the experiment we wanted to look
at DMA is so geographic level basically
TV markets for people who kind of aren't
as familiar with the marketing
terminology and in terms of steps we
knew that we wanted to somehow be able
to assign these different EMA's to
either treatment or control or you know
simply leave them out and then
eventually run the experiment expose
those in the treatment group to that
increased ad spend new type of ad and
then in the control just keep things BAU
and then eventually somehow we have to
estimate the incremental cost of the
campaign because what the YouTube the
thing is because the cost structure is
dependent on who converts you can't just
say I know I'm going to spend an extra
250 K it's dependent on the people who
are taking that action and it's not a
sure thing so you actually have to
figure out yeah what is that extra
amount there in addition to the
incremental conversions that you're
getting it's a little bit of a
complication and yeah like it can
definitely be hard like let's say that
instead of running an experiment someone
just rolled out this new cadre of ads
and you know what there are some things
that you could try and do you could
simply compare the difference in
conversions and spend after you started
running those campaigns versus before so
that's more of a traditional method like
difference-in-differences however what
that might not necessarily take care of
is that there are confounding factors
that might get in the way for instance
you know what if during that time
and that you release that new string
pads you also start offering a higher
discount for your new customers you
can't necessarily say that the
difference that you view in conversions
and spending after biffer versus before
it's because of that add any more
complicated another thing that could
happen or another way to kind of
approach this is try and identify who
saw versus didn't see the ad or
attractively and then compare conversion
rates for the two and the spend between
the two but it could be hard to get that
data and also it's really hard to know
like how much extra you spent between
the two groups and you know calling back
to Mike's talk if you actually attended
his about propensity score matching it
could be that there's some latent
variable that's biasing people who do
see the ad to be completely different
and not really overlapping so much with
the people who did not see the ad so you
know what do we do well one way that we
can try and help avoid this situation is
to set up a geo experiment they're very
popular so basically it entails
assigning non-overlapping geographic
regions to either a treatment or control
group or Sibley you know just leave them
out an absent of any sort of like
interventions that may be happening in
your pretest period or any underlying
confounding variables that could be
getting in the way what you should be
looking for is that in aggregate your
treatment and your control group should
be similar in terms of both your event
of interest so in our case it was
conversions as well as just main
predictors so it could be marketing
spending over time it could be session
traffic over time so looking at those
sorts of things in terms of stages
basically geo experiments tend to break
out down into three the pre period what
you'll want to do is choose a period of
time that you've is long enough that you
feel confident that you can gain insight
into the relationship between your
treatment group response variable and
your control group variables and also
within your pre period what you don't
want to do is be choosing a period of
time when your business is acting you
know not really according to normal so
if you're ramping up for Black Friday or
something like that probably not a good
period of time to be choosing to you
know build a pre period kind of baseline
for this sort of test or you know run a
test directly after it so just be
careful of that for the test period what
you'll want to do is you know look at
the volume of the events that you're
interested in figure out whether that
difference that you potentially will
measure between the treatment and
control group is enough to come to a
conclusion about whether it's
significantly different and you know you
also want to take into account any costs
associated with the campaign because you
know maybe it'll take six weeks but how
much is that going to actually mean that
your company is going to have to spend
to run that sort of test you know maybe
you end up having to choose more regions
to put in the test group or something
like this if it's not too costly to do
that and then finally typically if your
event of interest has some sort of delay
associated with it so like in the
YouTube ad maybe people aren't going to
convert right when they see it we might
want to leave an extra week or two to
see if there's kind of a live and that
effect and measure those extra
conversions that may be coming in
because of your activity another nice
thing about having a post period or a
cool-down period is that it can kind of
be an extra check to the fact that there
wasn't some sort of confounding variable
that happened during your test period so
you kind of want to see just a gradual
delay in your decay really in that
effect rather than it just dropping to
nothing once you get to that period all
right
so in terms of the actual setup you know
again the first step is assigning those
regions to the two groups and you know
in terms of ensuring that those groups
are similar based on your pre period
data there are a couple of different
approaches the simpler one is just
stratified random sampling so you know
back to that point about confounding
variables those could be really good
candidates that you want to look at in
terms of building your strata so
typically it could be like the size of
your geographic areas like you don't
necessarily want New York LA and Chicago
to all be in test group
it's not gonna be good for you that's
the thing another way that you could go
about this is mashing your markets or
you know groups of markets based on time
series modeling so there's one kind of
interesting approach that is called
dynamic time warping I'm not going to
get into that right now in the interest
of time and maybe you know questions
later but definitely check it out and
then after you have assigned to your
groups and kind of nailed down what
those are you're going to run your
experiment and at the end of that
cooldown period if you've elected to
have one you are going to somehow I have
to measure the effect of your marketing
intervention traditionally as I kind of
mentioned before you could do
difference-in-differences which would
kind of look like this you just take the
difference in test versus control after
versus before say that's conversion rate
do the same thing with spent
but the problem is what if there's you
know a really crazy spike in one of
those trends if you just look at the
mean that's not gonna be the best
representation as I'm sure we all are
aware so not always the greatest and of
course the confounders alternatively
what we could do is more of a causal
impact approach so this is a model that
will take information about how the
relationship between the treatment kind
of response variable and your control
group looks like kind of models that out
and then what that allows you to do is
make a prediction of what would have
happened in your treatment group had it
not been exposed to that extra spend and
finally you just compare the difference
between what you actually observed and
what that model says would have happened
and you can get a pretty good reading on
your lift so and more about the model
required inputs you are definitely going
to want your response time series so say
it's your treatment group conversions
you're also going to want a control time
series to kind of build that model on it
could be controlled group conversions
like you know definitely by all means
add other variables to it if they're
meaningful so maybe it could be you know
number of sessions in the control group
maybe that's predictive and then
eventually you use those inputs to build
this bayesian structural time series
model which kind of just takes
information about what happened
previously like what that relationship
looks like and allows me to predict that
counterfactual so like what would we
have observed in the treatment group in
the absence of that intervention for
your marketing campaign and that
difference between observed and the
counterfactual is going to be your
incremental effect and kind of like the
way that these results tend to get
visualized is in
this set of three plots and I'm going to
take you through so this is kind of just
the normal view where the solid black
line is just the trend of your response
variable the vertical line is when that
intervention started happening and the
dotted line the kind of tracks along the
solid black line is what the model
predicts would happen based on the
information from your control variables
and as you can see only one sided for
intervention hits the difference between
the dotted line and the solid line
really spikes a lot and typically the
next plot that you'll see is this sort
of pointed wise sort of representation
of that view so I mean ideally when you
are building your model the pre period
should be very close to zero
shouldn't really be any trend in the
error there otherwise maybe evaluate
adding more variables changing your test
versus control something like that but
this looks good and then intervention
hits immediately you know it's hovering
around a difference of ten and then this
is the same sort of view except it's
just cumulative over the points and I'm
just going to quickly run through how
one might do this in Python typically
these packages are more of an our domain
the original causal impact package was
built by the lovely people at Google and
I definitely still use it as benchmark
for results that I get in the Python
packages but this is one way to do it so
in terms of installation super simple
the package that I use just a pimp
install PI causal impact and then that
r1c
have it installed which if you're
working in an anaconda environment I
don't believe I had to install anything
extra in order to get it to just
completely install without issues then I
just imported causal impact function
from causal impact as well as just some
helper packages that I needed for my
analysis and then you know just setting
some visualization settings suppressing
warnings in case and then you know once
we have that all in just like load and
examine the input data so one thing as I
kind of hinted at before is that in
order for us to be able to determine the
incremental cost per conversion we
needed to build a model on conversions
as well as a model on cost so we have a
conversion data frame just looking at
the head the key thing here is that in
order to use this package and not have
it break is your response variable is
going to have to be at the far left and
then followed by any control variables
you have same thing for the costume is
that big data it's fake so moving on
from there just quickly wanted to do a
visualization of you know the two trends
together left axis shows the treatment
group in this case it looks like we had
fewer regions assigned to there versus
the control group but you know after the
intervention period it does look like at
least in this chunk we're seeing some
lifts there that's promising
maybe we'll find out when we build a
model in order to do that though we need
to figure out you know when the pre
period is and when the test period is
and in this I'm including the post
period so we did have a cool-down so I
just have a list of dates and I'm going
to figure out just like
where they are in the set I could have
easily put in the index but still a me
so that's another input that you're
going to eventually need to eventually
run your causal impact model so you're
going to want to have a list of two
dates the start of the pre period end of
the pre period started the post period
end of the post period and then we kind
of get to the fun bit causal impact
model very simple to call there are
three required arguments you have your
data set here I just use two variables
you know your response and then control
group conversions pre period you know
the set of the list of the two days post
periods same thing alpha so you can kind
of use your discretion here basically
you know it'll give you the probability
of accidentally rejecting your null
hypothesis basically that there was no
effect of the campaign on conversions
when it actually when there actually
wasn't in fact here we decided to kind
of set it to 0.1 by default it says 2.05
and there are other parameters which you
know we can talk about later as well but
in terms of you know once you've
actually called that function mil that
model here's what you'd expect from an
output like we just wanted to see a
quick nice plot of the results and
basically it's why kind of walked us
through before you know those actual
observed versus predicted in a normal
view and then your point wise estimate
sort of of difference between actual and
predicted and then your accumulative
some of those points
and then finally you know the main
question is how many incremental
conversions did we get from this within
that green box we have that cumulative
absolute sort of incremental number
estimate and because I wanted to have my
alpha set to 0.1 it returns a 90%
confidence interval so we should be that
degree confident that because of this
campaign the extra number of conversions
that we got is somewhere between around
698 and 1,000 420 and that's pretty good
looks nice there was a causal impact
according to this we're gonna want to
repeat that process for the cost data so
then we can get kind of our average
incremental cost per conversion estimate
and then because this package does
return intervals around the estimates
you could kind of give your stakeholders
a best-case scenario eyes CAC or a worst
case scenario so you know if they're
really cautious about it that's sort of
hopefully the worst at least with a 90%
confidence that they could expect to
happen so that's pretty much all it
takes and you know from here it's just
conclusions are that you know at least
at hellofresh and I'm sure in a lot of
the businesses that you all work with
there's a lot of marketing activity
going on um if it's you know very
consumer centric b2c and it's really
hard when you have all that stuff going
on to cut through the noise so to speak
and determine whether any particular one
actually had an impact and I think that
using these two techniques together if
you do have the luxury of you know
planning for an experiment definitely
allows us
at hellofresh to answer these sorts of
questions with a greater degree of
confidence then a post-hoc sort of
analysis you know just random assignment
of the geographies and having that
period split really helps us to make
sure that it really was because of the
campaign and not just some random
confounding variable that was driving
that and then the model you know it just
uses that for previous information about
how your variable of interest in your
regions of interest relates to other
factors that are predictive of it and so
that really gives you more of a
confident estimate on what that
incremental lift is and finally just you
know traditionally yes
as I mentioned our has been more the
realm in which these things have been
developed but you know Python yay we're
getting there
and there's that Python package for
causal impact and you know if you all
know any sort of packages out there that
help with the selection of markets and
you definitely hit me up because I can
add that to my appendix which I'll also
provide to you here and I guess that's
everything for me and questions
[Applause]
yes definitely like I think the sample
size would just like the power analysis
that goes behind just like if I want to
measure this amount of increase between
my treatment and my control group like
how big of a sample am I going to need
how long is that going to take given
what we've seen happening in our market
in the past or in the markets in the
past and how much it's going to cost
like that piece of it sort of like
mapping out that test period length I
think that's a big decision when I think
back to just the times when I've advised
on tests like those are the questions
that stakeholders and I mean honestly us
as well so that we can get a good
measurement are pretty concerned with
hmm yeah I guess like in that case maybe
it would be more of a situation where
you try like a post hoc analysis like
maybe with this propensity score
matching technique that Mike's
presentation touched upon also I guess
causal impact is a sort of package where
if you didn't run an experiment you
could also throw in some control
variables that map back to you what do
you think was impacting your event of
interest and just see what happens yes
like oh yeah okay yeah so in the case of
the Python package it is some sort of a
variation on Bayesian structural time
series so it's kind of taking you know
the observed data plus how that data
trends and changes over time and sort of
those are the main components and
there's a bit of you know this kink
where it's like if you see that your
control series is not very predictive of
what's happening in the treatment then
there's this sort of random variable
that will kind of play in more of a role
in order to kind of compensate for the
fact that your predictor isn't really
doing it so that's like the underlying
model for Python I think with the R
package it's slightly different but
definitely that is one of the main
parameters that I didn't get to touch on
in the presentation is that you can
switch out the model for something that
you've built in Housley if you feel like
that's a better representation
yes yeah so I think one possible way is
that you kind of minimize the difference
between just like the trend of
conversions over time during your pre
period and like you could use like
variables just like maybe if you're
building a time series model based on
what's happening in your control TMA's
the dynamic time warping is this thing
where it looks not necessarily as at the
very points in time and compares them
straight up but if there's a little bit
of a lag in one series but the trend
overall is still quite similar it'll
choose that as a control and I mean I'm
sorry to say but market matching it's an
hour package I've used that in the past
in order to kind of help me choose
similar regions yes
yeah I mean I think like the main thing
would just be like being more confident
that you're taking care of your
confounding variables so I mean I think
partially if you do select your DMA is
with that knowledge and kind of domain
expertise about what's happened in those
markets in the past in mind like that
should reduce that risk but I think with
the modeling aspect of it and it not
being just a singular point estimate
just building that counterfactual out is
a bit more helpful as we've seen it I
don't think that we've necessarily done
a straight comparison between the two
but at least within causal impact that
we've kind of checked out what's the
difference between the Python and our
packages were returning I believe that
with Python the interval tends to be
tighter and I think also there's this
thing called time-based regression which
is more for when your set of DM Aizaz of
a smaller size and it's supposed to be
more of a controlled experiment kind of
thing unfortunately I believe that's
also only an AR yes I think yeah like a
definitely a combination of the cost
like for sure just like if we know that
based on the number of inversions that
we tend to see what this group of dma is
versus that group if we want to measure
a 5% increase versus the control that
set of ads is going to have to run for
three weeks and it costs you know 250 K
or something and that's over budget then
it's sort of tricky but I think those
main thing
others okay thank you
[Applause]